[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
it looks like sony sony japan that is
might have pulled a whoopsie this
morning by
releasing this on accident it's a mini
teaser trailer of the actual teaser
trailer it simply tells us
when the release date is going to be
however it is unconfirmed right now if
this
is indeed legitimate this is going
around
everywhere online right now and if this
is true then well
we only have three days to wait until we
get the official spider-man no way home
teaser now i found out a little bit of
spider-man
no way home teaser trailer information
that i'll share some of in this video
and i also have found out that there are
actually some plot leaks out there that
are
very very true and that's what i'm going
to be discussing
in this video so if you love spiderman
and want to stay up to date on no way
home be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
but before we get started big thank you
to skillshare for sponsoring this video
skillshare is an
online learning community that offers
thousands of classes for creative people
and i personally am a huge advocate of
skillshare i view skillshare to take
classes about youtube about photoshop
about final cut pro and other editing
software
and if you're looking to do youtube
yourself it's a great place to learn
everything you need to know
i also use it personally i used to use
it to learn how to play guitar better
and now i'm using it to try and learn
how to sing better
if you are looking for a place to
explore your creativity or to simply get
better at things skillshare
is the perfect place to learn all of
these things and the great news is is
the first thousand of my subscribers to
click the link in the description will
get a one month free trial of skillshare
so you can start exploring your
creativity today just click the link in
the description down below to get
started
now i'm gonna go ahead and say that this
leak is
probably fake even if the trailer does
come out on july 22nd i still believe
that this particular video
isn't real my main thinking behind this
is that there's a really weird
spider-man in the beginning that seems
to be edited in
and his shoulder's just covering the
release date which apparently is july
22nd
one it seems like this is really not
very good editing and two
it's a little too convenient that his
shoulder is barely covering the release
date if sony japan
or sony in general were going to put out
a teaser for a teaser they would
actually give us the date they wouldn't
just show part of it and that's really
my main reasoning for thinking that this
is probably not too legitimate however
i do believe the trailer is coming soon
and i'll tell you a little bit on what i
know
for starters as some of you may know
because i've mentioned it a few times i
have two trailer sources
from all the way back to avengers in
game to
xiang chi to the eternals to the what if
trailer dropping the other week they've
all been right about the release dates
however there is a little bit of a catch
they usually don't find out when the
trailers are dropping until a few days
before
so i checked with both of my sources
they haven't heard anything yet but what
i have heard and seen online from
legitimate sources and people
is that the trailer is expected to come
out between now and the release of
marvel's what if on disney plus which
comes out august 11th so
there's only about a 20-day window in
which the spider-man trailer could come
out right now
assuming that the sources are correct
about the window and right now that's
really all that we've heard
unfortunately i do think that this is
fake but of course
is always the possibility that it could
be real and yes spiderman no way home is
the worst kept secret in hollywood right
now but i'm not sure
if sony japan or anybody else from sony
is dropping
teasers about the teaser if they are
what an interesting tactic
and i mean hey it's gonna work but we'll
have to wait and see on that now
like i said i have heard things about
some specific plot leaks out there
and one of them out there is very
legitimate and of course i'm going to go
over it and i've actually gone over it
before this was before i had
any confirmation that it was indeed real
and typically with plot leaks there's
always typically
something that is true about it we've
learned since avengers infinity war and
avengers in game and the rest of the
movies and shows that have come out
typically with plot leaks there are
aspects of each plot leak that
is real however with this particular
plot leak i've been told that pretty
much all of it is legitimate and i've
even seen some people online like grace
randolph stating that there
is a 100 real plot leak out there online
right now and i believe
it's this one so if you don't want to
really know now is your chance to click
away
i will say it's what we've been talking
about this entire time so it won't be
that big of a surprise but it sure
is exciting so let's go again i've
talked about this one before
but let's talk about it like this is
actually what is going to happen
it starts off by saying peter's life is
ruined after his identity was revealed
at the end of the last
spider-man movie spider-man no way home
he is now facing trial
and matt murdock is his lawyer peter
goes to doctor strange and asks him to
cast a spell to make everyone forget
that he
is spider-man doctor strange actually
agrees to this but
something goes wrong with the spell and
they break reality and bring
five spider-man villains of other
dimensions into the marvel cinematic
universe
the green goblin from spider-man 1 doc
ock from spider-man 2
the sandman from spider-man 3 lizard
from the amazing spider-man
and electro from the amazing spider-man
2. norman osborne is talking to the
others asking
what is the last thing that they
remember and they all say that
spider-man killed them that's the last
thing they remember
dying at the hands of spider-man and
this is what each of them individually
say
doctor strange wants to take them back
to their original dimensions but the
villains fear that returning would mean
that they would return
exactly where they came from meaning
they would die again
at the hands of spider-man doctor
strange is keeping all of these villains
trapped in a magical prison
and peter doesn't really feel right
about that so norman osborn aka the
green goblin manipulates peter into
freeing them making him feel
guilty for their deaths this leads to a
major conflict between doctor strange
and peter parker
so peter fights doctor strange and
breaks the key which is a cube
that held them captive in the prison and
the villains are now
free they start destroying parts of new
york and to stop them
peter somehow brings toby maguire
spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man into the marvel cinematic
universe
then there's a big rematch between toby
maguire spider-man
and doc op from spider-man 2 a big
rematch between andrew garfield
spider-man and electro from the amazing
spider-man 2
and then the final battle is going to be
at the statue of liberty with the three
spider-mans fighting together
fighting the sinister six and the person
who provided this plot leak said to be
clear i have no idea who the sixth
member is or
when and how he comes to the scene and
that very well could mean that it's
going to be a villain from
our own universe since all of these
other characters are indeed multiversal
villains it would make sense to have at
least
one villain from our own universe heck
maybe even mysterio is alive which is
something that i
kind of believe and hope for and i
wouldn't put it past the master of
illusions mysterio to still be alive
his whole death being a grand illusion
but this
is the plot leak now let's talk about
some key parts to this
one key part is actually something that
we've been hearing for a very long time
it was reported on well over a year ago
that spider-man himself
peter parker would actually be
responsible for releasing the villains
now at first that was really all of the
context that we were given just that
spider-man releases the villains we
didn't really know what that meant
though
however now we do doctor strange
actually puts them in a magical prison
then peter parker releases them that's
how it happens
now as far as the villains actually
coming into our reality
loki kind of explains how this could
happen the multiverse is now
a thing there are tons and tons of
branch alternate timelines
and there weren't before there was just
one sacred timeline and perhaps doctor
strange although i would find it very
odd if he didn't know but perhaps he
doesn't know about all of these
alternate branches yet
because that could be happening at the
exact same time he's dealing with peter
parker so he casts a spell that before
probably wouldn't have been that big of
a deal but now since there are multiple
timelines and branches it is a big deal
and it does
actually affect the multiverse and this
could be how they come in doctor strange
isn't aware that another timeline is so
close to theirs
so the spell ends up bringing other
variants into the mcu
and from here something else that is in
this plotlike that has been talked about
for a while is that peter parker and
doctor strange
aren't going to agree on something well
we now know what that is
it's the fact that doctor strange is
holding these villains in a prison cell
and wants to send them back to their
original timelines
now of course this would in turn kill
them because that's what was going to
happen to them before
spider-man killing them so are peter
parker being a spider-man variant
feels guilty about this and somewhat
responsible since they are dying to
a spider-man even though it's not him so
this is clearly
their disagreement doctor strange thinks
they should be sent back
even if it's going to kill them and
peter parker disagrees whatever peter's
solution could have been on how to save
them
who knows but it doesn't matter because
he ends up breaking them out and they
end up causing havoc on new york and the
final scene is on the statue of liberty
which we actually know this to be real
as well
we've actually seen leaked photos of the
statue of liberty on the spider-man set
and we've actually seen the statue of
liberty holding a captain america shield
so
who knows what's happening there but
exciting nonetheless so
be sure to let me know what you think
about this plot leak as i've been told
that it is pretty much legitimate this
is probably what we're going to be
seeing in spider-man no way home so
let me know your thoughts on this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and of course for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof